[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
perdons la vie
tu marches
sans savoir également où tu vas tu
repasses à ta vie
déjà
tu comptes combien de gens tu as déjà
trahi
on vient de gens qui tu as déjà menti
combien de gens tu es déjà fait souffrir
et du fond de ton remord
tu es mon corps
tu es prisonniers de ton secret
mais très loin
[Musique]
j'ai mal dans ta
sans jamais pour autant jamais consommé
galère
[Musique]
dans cette ville de millionnaire du
retail
et au fond qu'est-ce que ça peut faire
[Musique]
sans le temps
te sourit à tout le monde
tu es prisonniers le temps secret
[Musique]
le dépasse ta faute
comme ta vie doit être une longue nuit
pour nous dire
[Musique]
quelque chose dans ta vie
s'en va
tu ne sais plus réellement quoi penses
tu n'as plus l'état
du génie
tu n'as plus l'état c'est de la vie tu
es malade
sous la tunnel plus ton livre
même si du fond le temps
tu souris à tout le monde
j'ai prisonnier le temps sous-trait
mais tard
[Musique]
une longue nuit
peut-être une comédie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]